the league maybe Italy's most popular
political party but it's causing a lot
of consternation with its hardline on
migration and its attempt to form a hard
right populist movement across Europe my
guest this week here in Brussels is one
of their MVPs Markos Ani is there love
putin hate macro formula really such a
winner
[Music]
[Music]
Marko's Annie welcome to conflict zone
hello when your party the league came to
power it promised to be different from
other governments did that include
insulting France and its president and
its government for instance no I think
that that it's it's normal political
opposition there that they this
government and material salvini are
challenging people and politicians or
governments that have different ideas
especially on the future this is a bit
more than normal though isn't it in
France they have a bad government and a
bad president you know mr. Sabinas
that's something that that is showing up
in France with a lot of unusual protests
from French citizens and and we are
supporting French citizens in in
challenging governments in the with
which they are we are supporting our
allies in the European Parliament that
is marine lepen and it's clear that that
we are free to criticize proposals also
regarding the future of the European
Union by any governments in the you and
also consider way beyond that you're
supporting a group but once macro out
macro resign yellow vests against the
state this is an opposition movement and
you are interfering in France's no we
are not supporting it we are not
interfering they don't come to Italy and
we have said wrong expressing their view
on the Italian government many times
also other politicians that this
government is a populist economic death
in your government binary yeah they
mention it mr. salvini they mention it
leaked so that's the position of the
French government on mr. Makran and
that's the position on a lot of
establishment or traditional European
parties in the European Parliament so
you say you saying it hurt your feelings
today yeah I mean it's normal politics
in my view it will show you enough
respect it's no I mean they have a
different view they criticize it the
Italian the new it
government Khalid as populistic
xenophobic are people that are against
the poor people coming from Africa so
it's I mean for us it's normal politics
to too challenging or to criticizing
parties in Europe that have different
ideas than them as you say it's normal
they say crosses a big diplomatic red
line I don't think that we is this how
you propose conducting diplomatic
relations with other sites in the
European Union to tell them that they
have a bad government and the French
could do debt since when you since when
is it your business who the French elect
clearly the president is that your
business could have better government
and and we are supporting them
it's our business to say that we have
allies all around Europe our franchise
is marine lepen and if French people is
not happy with the proposal also
regarding the future of the European
Union in French we are we are able to
support our allies in any country if not
I mean the European Union makes no sense
it is there if there is so we expect you
to go out and stop other governments you
know you are you are setting up
something that is is not true I mean
France is your Minister Natalie Russell
said instead of engaging in a
competition of the stupidest that's the
opinion of the French Minister she's
able to state anything about or whatever
that doesn't change the position of the
Italian government and my party about
what is happening in Europe and in
France do you think you can't leave why
what is what do you think you achieve we
are setting we are challenging people
and parties that are destroying Europe
and mr. macron and you morning much for
your relationship between France and
Italy we have a relationship with French
parties our allies it's my real
pettiness also to hide on the government
to hell with the government you don't
like it you will be gone I mean that
even though
as you best what French people is asking
so what about the European Union
interfering as you are saying in foreign
politics criticizing another government
is also foreign policies that that's not
it's something if we have European
people if we have European politics that
is normal that there are critics and
relationship between European
governments yes this is this is a
convenient way to deflect attention now
from the currency I mean no not at all
our because isn't it really no not at
all we are showing up there that other
governments are asking Italy to to
welcome migrants but when we are asking
them to take care of their part of this
business or of this problem they are
just shooting up to and you say they're
refusing refusing to welcome parts of
refugees and France and Spain
governments that's what they do is
looking to you about what you're doing a
court has now decided that your party
leader Interior Minister Deputy Prime
Minister mr. salvini can be tried on
charges of kidnapping after refusing for
six days to allow migrants to disembark
from a boat in Sicily now the Senate has
to vote on whether he will get a trial
if he goes to trial your party's in big
trouble is not at all I mean it's it's
the normal Jews and and and are free to
go on with their mandate to investigate
if they see that there could be a breach
of the law but being put on trial is not
being contaminant for something your
photo Alliance your five star movement
Alliance has said that if a Minister
serving Minister is indicted or
investigating he has to step down that's
their position
no I told that's not the position so
five stars that's what they said many
times you said it luigi de Mayo is said
that since mr. Salvi knees
say that he can be investigated so he
has no problems at all in being
investigated for for this finger they
will support the judge and they they are
not changing I mean if you if you take
all the informations that Italian media
publish about the story then you can be
a little bit confused but the reality is
very different
the five stars had never said to that
mr. Cellini has to step it is their
principle and they've said it about a
previous interior ministry as well when
he if he was put what if one is
contaminated that's a reason also mean
the five-star routes move the goalposts
are wrong perception of what is five
stars
what are their rules I mean the CAF you
said you said that your policies are not
controversial the Catholic Bishops would
disagree with you
they said the solutions to the refugee
crisis do not lie in looking away saying
harsh words or being aggressive
we cannot let anxiety and fear condition
our choices they feed a climate of
disdain of anger and rejection disdain
anger and rejection that's what they say
you have created so we we are waiting
the Italian church to take the burden of
the refugees because I don't see bishops
or the Vatican States to take or to make
concrete acts to support refugees they
are just they're not addressing it so we
are protecting Italian people from
illegal migrants flu and the impact of
the wrong policies regarding the
migration issues by previous board
government is arming deeply Italy and
Italians voters and say you are harming
Italy last August anti-racist Grammy in
what was a dangerous acceleration in
attacks on immigrants
the result of your propagated fake news
in democracy the vote of people is the
way to judge a government and also after
the huge amount of critics that people
that are not sharing the view of this
government in Italy or abroad about
migration policy Italian people are
still strongly support the policies
especially in the migration which
publishes quarterly reports on racially
motivated what they say they say
propaganda around anti-migrant policies
has clearly contributed to creating a
climate of hostility and to legitimizing
racist violence the president of the
National Association of Italian
partisans
he said the extreme right has found a
party that's your party through which it
can speak from the numbers and the
statistic there is no evidence that
there is any increase in the so called
rat racism or acts against me grunts
that's not what these groups say no they
don't they don't show statistic they
just say bad words because they don't
like this government in that trance I
said in the two months after Matteo
salvini became interior minister they
reported 12 shootings two murders and 33
physical assaults on migrants in the two
months since he became death that
normally happen at that before this
government and is still happening and I
hope and I think that thanks to the
policy of mr. salvini and of this
government with less illegal immigration
coming to Italy all those things will
drop down so that that's my view and
that you keep in your party who is the
extremist let's take Roberto Calderoni
for instance certain culturally has no
official role in the government and in
the party he was in Europe
for a lot of people were in our heart
whenever he saw pictures of the black
politician says he can get now an MEP
said I cannot think of the features of
an orangutan I said mr. Calderon is not
a senior member of this how about Murray
of Borghese one of your MEP he had to
pay a fifty thousand euro fine for
calling prime minister Enrico letters
administration was horrible he was wrong
he was condemned by the party he was
fine it and he has to pay for his
mistakes that that's normal I mean we
cannot control every declaration of any
peace or whatever when the exact people
like that's a different party Mario
Borghese Oh was part of the old league
he will not be candidate anymore in the
Indian FC European Parliament mr. Sethi
was part of the old league as well but
he's elected secretary in 2014 and he
changed deeply the party and as I said
it was able to make the policies that
Italian people are asking if he is wrong
death will be decided by Italian voters
do you not by NGOs paid by someone not
by other people that have different
interest not by the Italian church but
just by the Italian people I'm happy are
you happy that black athletes in Italy
have become frequent targets black
athletes sports people have become
frequent target I mean if you're raised
along with this interview in this way I
will stop now because that's not an
interview why not no I am raising
important issues which worry people you
are attacking reading fake news this
isn't right and you not to waste my time
so see if you are going on in this way I
will leave immediately if you want to
know the price raise the issue our view
of the European if you have to go on
with this I mean I stop here because
this is not an interpret look and
venerate look I don't want to go on you
don't want to you don't want to go on
with you if you have serious question
about our policy proposal also
critic question but not going from the
first let me know I don't have time to
waste
okay questions about Saul's not
answering queries use no so if you have
questions about analyzation of the
league of this government our view about
the next European Union that's fine if
you want to go on asking fake news or
NGOs declaration of saying you may not
like these statements but they no I
don't want to waste my time in
everything an interview with the
journalist that is attacking from the
first second reading fake news I mean
that's not an interview so you are a
journalist I don't stand by the things
that you've said you don't want to stand
by the things that you've said but all
you arty leaders by what by what they've
said let's say mr. Salvi me last year
caused a shock at a European meeting
when he likened African immigrants to
slaves in Italy he said there's the need
to help our kids have kids not to have
new slaves to replace the children we're
not having that what is happening in
Italy and we are as we said in our
campaign Italy Italian first so we have
5 million poor people so people living
under the level of poverty in Italy and
it's the duty of the Italian government
to take care of those people not me
spending money to welcome or to support
tonight
do you think that's a nice way of a lot
of entrepreneurs or bad people in Italy
and all around Europe are exploiting
those people that are coming illegally
so they don't have documents they don't
have a status in Italy because they
cannot stay there to exploit them so we
are also preventing those people that
are coming illegally and then and
had to live behind the official official
way to be exploited by bad people in
Italy bad entrepreneurs and and that is
happening so and why me migrants were
bringing diseases into your country
that's that that scientific way I mean
they're not at all that's negative for
everything instead of just reading
statement by NGOs look at the numbers
and then you will understand by yourself
that those statements are just freak
news because there is no evidence in the
numbers that the politics of the new
government or what Matthew salvini is
saying is increasing the hate against
migrants or people that are not Italian
this isn't a game but is not this
government that is rising this thing
that's not isn't your real concern about
migrants that your white identity is
under threat isn't that the real reason
not that you've taken this hard that's
not a matter of white identity our the
league's responsible for immigration is
a guy coming from Senegal he was
entrepreneur in Italy so we are happy to
welcome people from outside the world
from Africa from also people that is
coming from another culture to help the
country to come legally in our country
and to contribute to the growth of our
country but they have to come legally
they have to understand that we have
limited capacity of of supporting
migration flows and they have to accept
our culture that's not saying that we
have to support just white people and we
are eating but last year the president
of Lombardi and a league official
Attilio Fontana he said on radio padania
that Italy must put an end to migrant
arrivals because they endanger the white
no not at all he said he didn't say that
we need to decide not to accept the our
culture our traditions soap in in that
sense our culture our heritage is in
danger if we agree to welcome a huge
amount of migrants from all around we
need to decide whether or not our ethnic
group our white race our society should
continue to exist that will be wiped out
no choice it's not a matter of white
race and mr. Attila Fontana had never
said this word he's referring as the
party is doing to our culture to our
sorry he apologized for it later he said
it was because he wasn't was a
misunderstanding
and he was not something that was
intended to be said by mr. Attila
Fontana that's why he's he clarified his
statement preventing through
mentalization of this and so what do you
want them with all this crackdown on
migrants you want to preserve your
identity as such we want to preserve the
Italian and European identity we want to
write ocean West parties across Europe
then you want to see more white people
pushing that idea the identitarian
concept it's not a matter of white
nationalist parties the league is not a
white nationalist party Lorenzo from
tamiya said he saw an identity rien
conception of politics awaking all
across human identity rien means white
know that that's what we are meeting
what it was to protect the European
identity the European Christian roots
for example the European culture the
Italian culture but is you that is is
giving to this identitarian project the
RS is the erratic development that's not
the meaning in any way that the ligand
and our
presenta these are doing so we want to
protect the cultural roots the Christian
roots of Europe and welcoming the people
that really are scared of for example
you are you are gone because the impact
of migration and control edna Gration
flows is not just a matter of protecting
cultural heritage but for example we are
living a deep impact on the level of
real wages so if you have a lot of
people that are coming illegally and
that are able or because they are
dispersed to be exploited or to make the
same job of European people for less
that's a problem economical problem so
the economic theory shows that and
control it and illegal migration flows
have an impact also on economy not only
in terms of down pressure on on real
wages but also on the money that
government has to spend in order to
create refugees camps in order to manage
migration flows we have more than
600,000 illegal migrants there's an
estimated and that's have a cost not
only in terms of internal security but
also economic impact on our budget so
that's not just saying we don't want
those people it's real problem let's
talk about Russia a country that you
seem determined to embrace in marked
contrast to your attitude to France your
leader mr. salvini says mr. Putin is one
of the best statesmen in the world yeah
I think that mr. Putin is doing very
well in in Russia he was able to put
again Russia at the center of the
geopolitical scenario
I mean I I want to be really frank if
you want to talk about politics if you
want to criticize our position it's good
please I don't have time to waste you
don't interest you if you wanna blame
I'm interested you aren't you are
worried why you think Russia is so great
I think that Russia has caused a number
of international crises like Malaysia
you are looking just at one side
I mean geo political clashes had a lot
of implications and not all the
responsibilities you by the Russian line
on that we are not buying the Russian
line we are seeing a cry of Crimea we
are saying that the there'd be mistakes
by both the sizes that economic
sanctions are not the right way to
convince Russia there is been a
referendum and if they want to stay in
countries you earn when you are really
bad you are really bad journalists you
are not making an interview you are just
using your role to blaming everything
and to and I will explain you the
position you can you you have a I'm
interested
[Music]
you
[Music]
you